european union agriculture ministers are
holding extraordinary talks in brussels
to discuss ways to help farmers hit by
russia's ban on imports of certain fresh
produce from the EU in august russia
announced a 12 month ban on mostly
perishable fruit and vegetables meat
fish and dairy products after the EU
imposed sanctions on Moscow over the
conflict in eastern Ukraine Russia's
band could hit EU exports worth more
than 5 billion euros several EU
technical meetings have been held since
August sixth when the band was announced
to define emergency support measures for
affected fruit and vegetable producers
in an immediate response to Russia's
move the EU set up an interim budget of
125 million euros and support and
earmarked more than 30 million euros in
emergency aid for peaches and nectarines
The ministers want to work out exactly
what consequences the ban will have on
European agricultural products what
produce should be eligible for EU
support and what kind of budget will be
needed to help struggling farmers to
protect farmers livelihoods countries
outside the EU have been encouraged not
to offer Russia cheap produce to replace
European products while the ban is in
place
Oh